we've spent two years getting this  together and there's been so much hard  work and effort and so today just you  know it's just signifies at the  beginning and that's just very exciting  he's the only guy for the job and you  know he did such a wonderful job the sky  fall and you know we came down to do the  next one and then just seemed to be the  obvious choice  it is the most exciting part of this  movie really or what are the most  exciting parts of this movie is that  we've got the chance to use better  organization and all that that brings  with it  not only have we got bad and Iommi  backward and and and and obviously Rafe  and Rory but um somehow we've managed to  attract this another some more amazing  people I don't know how we do it but  they seem to want to come and get  involved with the madness which is just  all our game  it's great I have a reckless one yet but  I will  you